so sitting here is George Lansky hello
Jordan hi
are you close enough to the microphone
you have to tell me that's not my
responsibility okay well why don't you
put the microphone a little closer to
your mouth
you are being an incredible prick
already I didn't realize it was
functioning as an audio engineer but I'm
happy to comply okay I'm not an audio
engineer but I could tell immediately I
don't know how these are calibrated
you've been in this studio many times
this is my first appearance okay you if
you're listening right now and you're
driving and you're uh clenching the
wheel angrily uh I apologize that's
because
like me when someone comes on and takes
an arrogant
inhuman tone you get upset why would you
assume I know how many inches this is
meant to be from my mouth that's like
quite an assumption that's a great yeah
how many inches is this from my mouth
you just opened yourself up to I mean if
the Impractical Jokers right now were on
the line they'd be having a blast you
how many inches is this from my mouth